no no no i wouldn't say that no if you
like if you're just saying overtly
racist [ __ ] yeah
you make like a bad comparison
yeah you know if you come off like joe
trying to find where atlanta is compared
to new york
yeah it's that's not like you know
homophobic that's just
ignorant what did carano say she said
she basically compared
political beliefs now being persecuted
to the fact that in 1940s germany
the way the nazis were so able to take
power
and do whatever they wanted was because
they they brainwashed citizens
into picking on their jewish neighbors
and eventually attacking their jewish
neighbors
and she said how is that any different
from attacking people for their
political beliefs i get what she was
trying to say
obviously any comparison to anything
with the holocaust
is very it's a shoddy comparison you're
going to piss people off
it's a dumb thing to do i'm not
disagreeing with any of that but here's
what bothered me
the grounds for her being fired based on
that opinion
was that she was somehow reducing the
plight of jewish people during world war
ii
okay i get that i understand that
perspective however
how is it any different from all the
people on the left
when trump got nominated or elected and
they said he's like hitler
how is that any different that's the
same reduction of
circumstance but on one side of that
coin it's okay to say and on the other
it's
it won't even be energy rosa that's an
interesting joke that's an interest joe
de rosa with an interesting take look at
you
judging you with your bed spreads there
and all of a sudden joe comes in
i just don't get this place that we're
in where there's
no room for discussion about anything
and and
because there's there's too many
channels joe there's too many channels
and then
you gotta like do sensational [ __ ] i
don't know what the [ __ ] it is i mean
i'm on that [ __ ] show now i gotta
watch what the [ __ ] i say
yeah i know
[Laughter]
yeah i'm a fan of that show we all
everybody what show is she
what shall we see on the mandalorian
star wars yeah [ __ ]
yeah they cancel their action figure
that's how deep cancer culture is they
cancel their action figure it's like
let the action figure come out did she
ever pony up to you bill i'm like bill i
got a few ideas i think
no she was an absolute sweetheart
yeah super nice [ __ ] person and you
know whatever and somehow someone will
take this video and they'll
[ __ ] make me say something else and
you know try to get rid of my bald
action figure
figure yeah do you have an action figure
no oh
no you [ __ ] nerds so
the thing with what she's saying here is
interesting
because she's not saying i think this is
more nuanced she's not saying that
what republicans go through is the same
as
what jews went through in nazi germany
right what she's saying is
this is the groundwork for what happened
to jews yes in other words you first
need to make it
okay to publicly hate someone and shame
them
and then you could do whatever you want
with those people
so do i think in america in the year
2021
that there's ever going to be a time
where we're just rounding up trump
supporters
half the country like you know how big
the [ __ ] camps are going to need to
be
like we didn't even have enough room for
the native americans there's no way
we're going to have enough room to put
74.
barely a minority barely a minority
barely
barely 49 49.5 percent
like so that can't happen like jews were
a super super small minority in
germany so this is completely
unrealistic but what she's saying is you
can't
allow hatred
towards a group of people because when
you openly hate a group of people
all of a sudden it becomes very easy to
inflict acts of violence
you can't make a person radioactive for
who they are that's kind of what you're
saying like yeah you're gonna hate this
person automatically because she's a
trumper
and when when they are when it's open to
hate them yeah
violence is very easy like remember a
punch a trump supporter or something
or punch a mega person yeah back in the
day like
it was just like a uh a saying so it's
like yeah they
we maga people are racist and the sexist
and all these other things so you might
as well just punch them in the face
and punch a nazi that was it but they
were referring to the mag of people
essentially and um it is kind of weird
that
nobody ever has issue the other way
around that's what i was gonna say
we've been comparing trump to hitler for
four years
now the comparisons are stronger than
ever nobody ever
says hey that's triggering do you
understand that hitler killed six that's
true
true like we can label that is really
interesting that's what bothers me about
this i think what she's saying is stupid
like i understand the general point that
she's trying to make and that's not
stupid she takes it to a stupid place
but people compare trump to hitler on
the other side for four years
and nobody's losing jobs yeah there
seems to be no issue with that
whatsoever
i don't think this is fireable i just
don't yeah you can call it stupid i do
i don't think it's fire but we also use
hyperbole
every single day yeah like that's what
we literally do
like what she's doing she's not doing it
for comedic purposes she's doing it for
dramatic purposes but like
for a living what we do is exaggerate
things so it's funny
so when we see someone else exaggerate
things we're like oh yeah that's
that's relatable that's what we do maybe
that's why it's not so shocking
but for these literalists right these
like suits these corporate [ __ ]
who don't know how to think outside of
like
right in front of their face maybe
they're just like uh oh people could
cancel their subscriptions if she's
maybe this is a stupid counter argument
but we even the way we all use language
like when people say literally it
doesn't mean literally anymore
gary goldman has a great bit about it
how like now it it's become
it even just means figuratively oh he's
literally a thousand pounds
yeah we all do that everybody
exaggerates language yes we all have a
boss that's a slave driver slave master
nobody's like
a stand-up so they get it in the office
we all say it so
i don't and you know what's interesting
she
actually knows a little bit about yeah i
didn't know that [ __ ]
neither did i i thought it was like
hitler turned on the light and then
that's
it with the jews i didn't know but it
makes way more sense that they slowly
need to gain support
yeah they slowly need to gain support
for this behavior yeah
and they tolerate these actions from
like the regular germans or in the
street not
i mean this is i don't know it's kind of
weird if
if you're jewish i'm really i'm really
curious if you're jewish
do you not agree with this on some level
i think ben shapiro supported her
actually
and he's you know head
media jew but like which is very much
had you
if your head meeting you you had a jew
boy
i'm also having a bad week because uh
you know i don't know i don't because of
social media took out
yet another friend of mine and i i just
don't know
i don't know it seems like now you can
literally make a statement that is
uninformed it's just unbelievable
it's it's unreal i mean just [ __ ]
i don't get it you know i don't agree
with what i read
but i mean do i think that then you
should just everybody gets the electric
chair there's just no
like hey you know uh you might want to
read up on this a little bit more before
you compare this to that you know
it's just like flamethrower lit
done [ __ ] crazy man
[ __ ] crazy crazy goddamn times
[Music]
this ufc girl that lost her job did you
see this this carano girl
yeah man as a jew i think it's not good
yeah what did you have any thoughts on
it man look i think
the equivalent it is a complete false
equivalency
of her what she's making here a complete
false equivalency the fact that
she has said some things that upset
people
and are going out there going after her
online is
not even close to what jews had to deal
with
in the 40s in germany oh yeah it's it's
not
even it's a however
the this is we we have to stop
canceling people for having different
ideas than we have
yeah that's it even if their ideas are
wrong even if their ideas are deemed
wrong yeah it's like it's gotten to this
place where it's like
if somebody because then you end up with
a herd of people who will just never say
anything but they're angry all the time
right
and so look it's nick cannon to me was
the best example
when i heard what he said i was like oh
this dude
just doesn't get he doesn't know yeah
he's yeah he's just reading like
somebody he watched some bad uh
malcolm malcolm x he's regurgitating
some
some false narratives and i'm not saying
malcolm x is bad i'm saying he watched
some outtake of fair con or something
like
there's some videos that get passed
around even by smart people that i know
that i'm like
are you serious what are you sharing
this
dude i could not agree with you one that
goes around it's like that oh
uh white people are afraid if black
people got in power that they would
treat
white people like they treated black
people and i'm like this is insane
i haven't seen that one is that a fair
con one yeah i think it was a fair
comment but just some of the stuff that
like
i don't know just like it's just so like
i i don't know
i just i can't believe some people would
share some things that they share you
know
i i just think this scene probably first
of all unnecessary i think if you feel
like
you can't be heard which i think you can
if you have
if you have like it's not even if you're
not like
almost openly because they had that
silence is violence thing
like during blm like if you're not
openly
liberal a lot of times i feel like you
definitely get stared at
for not making a lot of the same
statements you know um
this here's the thing man but like
we we're making people scared
to speak so you drive people underground
yeah and when you drive people
underground
what happens is they get angrier and
angrier and angrier and angrier
and then it probably erupts in something
like this and then something happens and
then something happens